SARA CHOWSKI: Hello, and
welcome to Verily's journey
to the cloud.
Today, we'll chat a bit
about Verily, who we are
and our background,
how we're developing
in the cloud, my
team, Verily Kumo,
and how we're enabling that
development in partnership
with Alphabet Cloud.
Some of the products
we've worked together
to build to enable that
cloud development to be more
efficient, the adoption
catalysts of those products,
and then deep dive into one
of the more recent products
we're excited about, Verily
Cloud, or App Factory.
And then we'll wrap
it up by chatting
about where Verily's looking for
the rest of 2020 in the cloud.
But first, we should
do introductions.
Hello, I'm Sara Chowski.
I work at Verily on
a team called Kumo,
and I'm joined by Tony Tseng
from Alphabet Cloud in Google.
So Verily-- Verily is Alphabet's
venture in healthcare.
We're focused on a focused
version of Google's mission,
to make the world's health
information useful so
that people enjoy
healthier lives.
We sit at the crux of healthcare
research, engineering,
and data informatics,
and we're focused
on an exponential
improvement of care.
So Verily was founded
as Google Life
Sciences in Google [x] in 2013.
We've grown since then,
changed our name to Verily,
and we now have
over 1,000 employees
in Verily and joint ventures.
We work with 32 top-tier pharma
and medical device companies.
And we partner in
three different spaces.
We partner across
care solutions,
where we work with health
systems and employers
to develop tools and
interventions optimizing
care delivery.
We work in research solutions,
creating an ecosystem
of sponsors and health systems
to accelerate studies and make
it easier to generate evidence.
And finally, we collaborate
in innovation solutions,
working together on next-gen
devices and connected solutions
that empower research
and care outside the four
walls of a clinic.
So one product Verily works
on is Project Baseline.
Project Baseline collects and
organizes terabytes of data
and is the future
of understanding
comprehensive health.
We collect data from
traditional sources,
like clinic healthcare
records, as well as
from more
non-traditional sources,
like data collected at home
about behavior and medication
and remote wearable
devices and location.
We pool together this data
and organize and aggregate it.
And using the Project Baseline
ecosystem we've built,
we improved the
speed and quality
of evidence generation of other
companies in pharma, device,
and health systems so that they
can focus on what they do best.
We sit at the center to
connect participants to studies
and develop technology
to enable studies
to move more efficiently.
And as you can imagine, these
partners and participants
have varying needs and
different infrastructure,
and we want to meet them
where they are and kind
of collaborate in a public
cloud, which has led us
to developing in the cloud.
As I said, we gain
several benefits
from the cloud, one of which
is co-development and data
sharing with partners.
We also get fast development
and prototyping from the cloud.
We reduce new hire ramp up time,
because all of the tool chains
are tool chains that new
hires are more familiar with,
as they're public.
And finally, we help Google
dogfood its GCP cloud offering.
Dogfood is a
tradition at Alphabet
where we kind of preview and
work with products before they
hit market and kind of
provide feedback and help
fine-tune these products.
So Verily's GCP history--
as you can see, our use
of GCP has just gone
up and to the right.
We've been adopting GCP
over the course of years,
and we've hit a lot of the
same cloud adoption pain
points that all
GCP customers hit.
A sample of these
hard challenges
include management of
external partners' access
to data, making sure that
if there are agreements
to acknowledge that these
partners do so before seeing
data, that their membership
would expire in a timely manner
and possibly be refreshed.
We worked to audit cloud
resources and their access,
make sure our IAM policies
are exactly what we want them
to be, and that we understand
who is accessing our data
and have technical
leads just kind of check
on and audit these accesses
and resources configuration
from time to time.
And finally, just streamline
of creation and management
of apps and resources.
And as we kind of hit
some of these roadblocks,
they've pushed us to create
new pieces of infrastructure
to solve these common
pain points together
with Verily and Alphabet.
And Alphabet Cloud is in the
process of productionizing
and releasing these products.
So my team, Verily Kumo, is
one of the central cloud-native
teams at Verily.
I learned, possibly too
many months into my tenure
on Kumo, that Kumo means
"cloud" in Japanese, which
is quite fitting for our team.
Our mission is to make
Verily's use of the cloud
safer, simpler, and
more secure by default.
We work with teams in Verily
and understand their use cases
and iterate on their
cloud resource management.
We collaborate
with Verily DevOps
to promote reliable and
sustainable software
development practices.
Kumo manages IAM best practices
and enforces Org policies
on our GCP resources,
to kind of make sure
that those resources
are following
the guidelines we need them to.
And finally, we helped develop
custom Terraform modules.
And these are fairly
specific Terraform
modules that enforce best
practices, consistency,
and security.
And they're used throughout
the company both directly
and, as you'll see later,
in App Factory as well.
And as I said, my
team collaborates
with Alphabet Cloud
to do all of this,
so I'll hand it over to Tony
to talk a bit about his team.
TONY TSENG: Thank you, Sarah.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Tony.
I'm one of the tech leads in the
Alphabet Cloud team at Google.
So our team was formed about
two and a half years ago,
and our team's mission
is to enable GCP adoption
across Alphabet companies
so that ultimately, we
can improve our platform and
the overall customer experience.
In other words, we're
here to reduce friction.
So in the past two
and a half years,
we have been using GCP like
an external customer would,
and we've seen our share
of friction points.
I'm going to quickly go
over three examples here,
and I suspect some of you might
have seen them before too.
The first example is Istio
to MySQL connectivity.
So that mTLS in this PERMISSIVE
mode does not work with MySQL.
You'll either need to change
it to strict or disable mTLS
altogether.
This is a well-documented issue
by now, but once in a while,
new people will still hit it.
The second example is automatic
HTTP to HTTPS redirect.
So earlier this year,
Google Cloud Load Balancer
rolled out this feature.
But before it was
available, we had
to add another layer
of load balancer
in order to do this redirect.
The third example is
about GCP API enablement.
So in our Terraform modules,
we need to conditionally
wait for an API to
be enabled before we
can do any kind of operation.
Otherwise, it's going
to result in an error.
So for some of these
friction points,
we'll try to add internal
priority so that the fixes can
be rolled out sooner.
And for others, we've created
workarounds and custom
solutions.
So as the next step
of custom solutions,
we have launched three internal
products within Verily.
The first product is
called Verily Groups.
Verily Groups is an
application layer
built on top of Google Groups.
It has two additional features.
The first one is
membership expiration.
Verily does not wish groups
to have permanent members.
Therefore, all members will
have an expiration period.
And also, when the
expiration time approaches,
notifications will be
sent out to both the group
admin and the group member.
The second key feature
is about data agreements.
So some of these groups are used
for access control purposes.
So before a member can
gain access to a group,
they have to acknowledge
some usage agreements.
And when an acknowledgment
has been made,
it will have to be
renewed periodically.
The second product
is called Aditum.
So Aditum is a service that
offers security, audit,
and cost control
governance for Verily.
It ingests GCP resource
metadata, audit logs,
and IAM policies in
order to generate
periodic reviews of reports
for Verily leads to review.
It also has integration
with Config Validator
so that it can scan for
anomalies and violations
in GCP resource configuration.
And finally, the third product
is called Verily Cloud.
Verily Cloud is a
Kubernetes-based application
platform created by
us in collaboration
with Verily teams.
We like it a lot
so far, and we're
planning to make it
available externally
under the name of App Factory.
So for the rest of
this presentation,
you might hear the names
Verily Cloud and App Factory
being used interchangeably.
The initial motivation for
us to create App Factory
is to reduce the
time to service.
The one common complaint that
we keep hearing over and over
again is that it takes
too long for a new team
to get started on cloud.
Oftentimes, a
developer will spend
a lot of time learning
about GCP configuration
details and their internal
security standards.
Now both of these
are really important,
but they don't
meaningfully contribute
to the quality of software
developer deployment.
They also don't change very
much from team to team.
Therefore, our hypothesis
is that by offering
an opinionated platform
with automatic guardrails,
we can significantly
reduce this ramp-up time.
There are four key
features of App Factory.
The first one is about cloud
resource configurations.
App Factory enables
you to define
custom abstractions of
cloud resources backed
by Terraform modules.
To use an analogy, instead
of a hardware store that
sells nuts and
bolts, App Factory
should be more like a furniture
store that sells fully
assembled desks and chairs.
In this basic usage, you can
have a one-to-one mapping
between App Factory resources
and cloud resources.
The only difference
there is that you
may take away a lot of
settings and replace them
with fixed values
that are appropriate
for your specific application.
But for most applications,
they need more than just
a cost-equal instance
or just a GCS
bucket or just Pub/Sub topic.
They actually need a suite
of different GCP resources
to work together
as a cohesive unit.
So App Factory enables
you to define this higher
level of abstraction.
So their developers
will only need
to deal with a single
logical entity, as opposed
to five or six or 10
different cloud resources.
The second key feature is about
rapid application development.
As a developer, I want to get
to the business logic part
as fast as possible.
I'm not very interested in the
boilerplate or bootstrap code.
App Factory enables you
to bring your own set
of service templates for
your developers to build on.
It is much easier to start
from a working example
than to start from scratch.
The third feature is
about the integration
with Git repositories.
So all the configurations are
stored in a Git repository.
So with a version
control system,
we get a few benefits for free.
We have code reviews.
We have audit logs.
We have the ability
to roll back.
We can also plug in
presubmit checks.
And finally, App
Factory is a bridge
between click-ops and Git-ops.
We recognize that not
everybody is a YAML enthusiast.
Somebody, or some of us, still
prefer to work with WebUI.
So App Factory can take
the input from WebUI
and generate a
corresponding pull request.
And also depending on
your specific setup,
you can choose to
skip the review part
and commit directly
to the repository.
And next, we're going to
show a demo of App Factory.
And after the demo, Sara
will go over the road map.
This is a demo for Verily Cloud.
Verily Cloud is an internal
application platform
built on Kubernetes.
It's proven to be
quite useful so far,
and we are exploring its utility
as an external product offering
under the name App Factory.
In this demo, we're going
to show the workflow
to create a cloud
environment on GCP
and to deploy a
simple application.
The first step is
to create a product.
A product on Verily
Cloud roughly maps
to a set of Git repositories,
cloud environments,
and software services.
In terms of the GCP
resource hierarchy,
you can think of a
product as a folder,
and there is one GCP
project per environment
underneath that
folder to contain
the environment-specific
resources.
Now let's go to the
product creation screen.
Other than the name
and description,
you will see that there are also
the IAM groups and Break-Glass
groups.
The IAM groups have read-only
permissions on prod and preprod
environments.
The Break-Glass groups
have full access.
Break-Glass comes from
the phrase "in case
of emergency, break glass."
Access to the group
is based on demand
and should only be done
when there is a need
to make emergency changes.
And the membership has
a short expiration time.
At the bottom here, you'll
see that Verily Cloud creates
five environments
by default. That's
based on Verily's standard
engineering practice,
and it is completely
customizable.
Now I'm going to enter
the product parameters
and start the creation process.
Going back to the
product list screen,
you can see that
the product is now
in the pending creation state.
Here is where Verily
Cloud makes the connection
between click-ops and Git-ops.
Verily Cloud has generated
a GitHub pull request
based on the product parameters
that we have specified earlier.
It's showing "Pending Creation"
because the pull request
has not been merged yet.
Let's review the pull request.
This pull request contains
multiple files and directories.
There is one directory
per environment.
And if we scroll
all the way down,
we'll see a product, that yaml
file, that contains the product
specification.
I'd like to call your
attention to these two fields.
Every product has a config
repo and a deployment repo.
Config repo is the
repository that we're
looking at right now.
It is meant to contain
human-readable configurations
at the right level
of abstraction
to be defined by your
infrastructure team.
The deployment repo contains the
fully expanded configurations
that can be directly applied
to the actuation layer.
In other words, it is
a two-step process.
Human-readable changes
in the config repo
will be translated into
machine-readable changes
in the deployment repo,
and then it'll be actuated.
Now I'm going to review and
approve and merge the request.
It will take about a minute to
complete the entire process.
After the product's
been created,
let's go to the product string.
In the left hand here, there is
a list of all the environments
associated with this product.
So right now, there's nothing
in my dev environment.
As my next step, I'm going
to create a new GKE cluster.
So other than the machine
type and node count,
there is nothing else
for me to change.
That's because the Verily
team has already pre-defined
all the rest of the parameters.
And after I hit
the Submit button,
it's going to trigger the
creation of another pull
request.
And then we can review it.
So the first thing here
on the pull request
is a Terraform plan output
that shows the expected changes
on the GCP side once this
pull request is merged.
If I scroll down a little bit,
other than the GKE cluster
configuration, there is
also the configuration
for the alert policies.
Again, I did not define these.
They have been created
already by the Verily teams.
And let's take a look
at the yaml file.
The email file is pretty simple.
It only contains the
parameters that I just
entered in the WebUI.
So I'm going to approve this
change and merge this request,
and the GKE clusters should
be ready in a few minutes.
My GKE cluster is
ready to serve now.
And I'm going to
add a service next.
At this point, I should
mention that both the resource
and service templates are
meant to be customized.
They should be tailor-made
to fit the exact needs
of your application team.
And here, I'm adding a
JAVA-based gRPC service.
And because I'm deploying
this my dev environment,
I'm going to specify that
a new rollout will be
created on every single commit.
And now a pull request should
be generated, and let's go ahead
and review it.
The interesting bit here is
that there is a repoURL field.
After this pull
request is merged,
it's going to create a new
repository of this location,
and it's going to
contain this simple code.
The service creation
has finished.
Let's take a look.
And this URL points to
the source repository that
contains the generated code.
And here, we can see that there
are a few build-related files.
And if we look inside
the source directory,
we'll see that we have the
protocol buffer definition, as
well as a Java skeleton code.
And because we specified
to rollout on every commit,
this initial commit should
generate a deployment
on my GKE cluster.
And here, let's take a
look at the Workloads page.
And the deployments are
already up and running.
And this concludes our demo.
Thank you.
SARA CHOWSKI: Welcome back,
and thanks for the demo, Tony.
As we look forward
to the rest of 2020
and Verily in the cloud, we
have a few projects in mind.
First, we want to work
towards enabling prototyping
playgrounds for developers.
As I said previously,
we've enabled
a lot of IAM best
practices and GCP Org
policies in our
organization hierarchy
to kind of keep data safe
and secure by default.
But this slows down the
great development velocity
we get when we use the cloud.
And so we want to be able to
enable playground life cycles
and make sure that developers
can easily deploy a project
and try some things without
going through a large exemption
process.
Looking towards
App Factory, we're
working to make templated
generic applications,
independent of
language or framework,
be able to be deployed.
We want to focus on
test infrastructure,
adding integration and load
testing that are easy to setup.
We want to work to support
more cloud resources.
And this is just increasing
the breadth of GCP resources
we have, as well as looking
potentially to multi-cloud,
being able to flex to
where our partners are.
We want to be able to customize
release management-- name
custom environments, add
additional environments,
and change release pipelines
to suit developer needs.
And finally, more generic
automatic monitoring setup,
so that when people
set up a project,
it just has that monitoring and
telemetry available for them
from the get-go.
And so that's what we
have for you today.
If you're interested
in anything we
talked about or using the tools
that Googlers and Alphabet use
to speed up their public
cloud adoption efforts,
please reach out to Doug Platts,
the Alphabet Cloud product
manager.
And thank you so much
for joining us today.